the good news is president Trump
scrapped plans this weekend to hold
secret talks with the Taliban at Camp
David just days before 9/11 the bad news
is President Trump had previously made
plans to negotiate with the Taliban at
Camp David just days before 9/11 we will
examine foreign policy follies from Bill
Clinton to Donald Trump then as
partisans on the left and right jump in
to attack President Trump as Trump gets
a new primary challenger in the
Republican Party we will agree with his
credits with one caveat President Trump
is the worst president in recent history
except for all of the other ones all
that and more I'm Michael Knowles and
this is the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Winston Churchill said it of democracy
said democracy is the worst form of
government except for all the other ones
that have been tried President Trump he
is the absolute worst president we've
had in recent history except for every
single other one and we will get to that
in one second particularly with this
Taliban blow up a totally self-inflicted
wound but first we need to talk about
something that really matters like the
importance of a good-looking dress shirt
do you ever wonder in this modern age
last really 10 15 years why traditional
button-up shirts look so long and baggy
and you just can't get them to look
right whether you're going out to a club
or whether you're going to work that's
me as those shirts were never meant to
be worn that way untuck it shirts
however were specifically designed to be
worn untucked they talked about
entrepreneurship and innovation actually
just identifying a problem and coming up
with a simple really crisp really
clean-cut solution that is what untuck
it did is a real problem and now they
have a real solution untuck it is the
brand that you have been looking for it
is the original untucked shirt a modern
solution to an old problem with no
tucking or tailoring required because
you go out you buy an expensive shirt or
something and then you got to get it
tailored to get the right fit you don't
need that with untuck it no matter your
size or shape their shirts are the
perfect untucked length I really love
untuck it you know I'd heard about it
from Jeremy the god-king boring long
before they ever sponsored the shows
Jeremy was a proselytizer of untuck it I
tried the Matt I love them they are just
terrific you can try one on in person
like I did at one of untuk its 50 stores
or you can go to untuck it calm to get
started they even offer free shipping
and returns on all orders in the u.s.
save 20% on your first order by using my
code MKS at checkout
Vanity Fair called me a dapper Lib
triggering troll you can be just as
dapper if you go to untuck it calm use
the promo code M K s all right now we'll
talk about less important matters like
negotiations with the Taliban and Camp
David the presidential retreat President
Trump we got word a couple days ago
actually I think was yesterday morning
this story broke president Trump
canceled what were secret talks planned
with the Taliban just days before the
18th anniversary of 9/11 and he does
deserve credit
for canceling those talks but he does
deserve some criticism for planning the
talks in the first place so what
happened President Trump tweeted about
this he explained the entire situation
he tweeted out quote unbeknownst to
almost everyone
the major Taliban leaders and separately
the president Afghanistan were going to
secretly meet with me at Camp David on
Sunday
they were coming to the United States
tonight unfortunately in order to build
false leverage they admitted to an
attack in Kabul that killed one of our
great great soldiers and 11 other people
I immediately cancelled the meeting and
called off peace negotiations what kind
of people would kill so many in order to
seemingly strengthen their bargaining
position they didn't they only made it
worse if they cannot agree to a
ceasefire during these very important
peace talks and would even kill twelve
innocent people then they probably don't
have the power to negotiate a meaningful
agreement anyway that's the key and they
probably don't have the power to
negotiate a meaningful agreement anyway
he concludes how many more decades are
they willing to fight that's the
question now just this tweet shows you
president from political acumen which is
he is blaming a Taliban attack that
killed one of our soldiers it just
happened last week he's blaming that
attack for calling off the peace
negotiations the Taliban have been
killing our soldiers for twenty years
there's nothing new about this attack so
the question is is President Trump
responding to an attack or is he using
the attack as an excuse to get out of
the meetings I think it's the latter I
think it's pretty clear that it's the
latter but I think it's wise for him to
do that it's a perfectly good way for
him to get out of having these meetings
the decision to disinvite them was a
good meeting
it shows reportedly a divide in the
Trump administration between Mike Pompeo
over at State Department and John Bolton
who is the national security adviser
we'll get into that in a second but we
we shouldn't narrow in on why this was
such a mistake in the first place why it
was such a mistake to invite them the
Taliban are the worst people on earth
they
should all be put to death as quickly as
possible every last one of them the only
way that I could get behind this meeting
happening is if Trump invited them all
into a room and then personally shivved
every single one of them they are little
devils all of whom who should be
executed by the United States of all of
the bad actors in the world the Taliban
are probably the most unrepentant
terrorists out there they worked
directly with Osama bin Laden they have
the most direct connection of any group
in the world to al-qaeda and to the 9/11
attacks most egregiously of all these
talks were scheduled just days before
the anniversary of 9/11 it's almost
cartoonish how bad the timing was this
was politically potentially a disastrous
situation even if the talks had gone
well even if they somehow got everyone
in the room the president of of
Afghanistan and the Taliban and the
President of the United States and they
said okay we're going to stop the war in
Afghanistan we've come to this political
solution even then it looks bad because
you were inviting people who were
responsible for 9/11 to US soil to the
presidential retreat misses as
prestigious a place as there is in the
entire country
just days before 9/11 it just looks like
a victory for them it looks like they're
gloating absolutely terrible and by the
way the talks wouldn't have gone well
they wouldn't have gone well as
president from concludes in his tweets
because there is no evidence whatsoever
that the Taliban can negotiate in good
faith they are demons they are Devils
and they should all be wiped off of the
earth only god can judge but the United
States can arrange the meeting and we
have done that with the Taliban and we
should do that with the Taliban they do
not have any redeeming qualities I don't
know how to put too fine a point on on
it people don't know this though people
don't know a lot about the Taliban they
know a lot about Isis they know a lot
about al Qaeda Isis spun off of al Qaeda
al qaeda was harbored by the Taliban but
I found even even in the 19 years or 18
years since the invasion of Afghanistan
people don't really know a lot about the
Taliban itself who are the Taliban
Taliban are a terrorist group that took
over Afghanistan in the mid 90s after
they took over everything got even worse
you'd think
things couldn't get worse in Afghanistan
they did infant mortality in Afghanistan
rose to the highest level in the world a
quarter of all Afghan Eze died before
the age of five under the Taliban they
committed war crimes with impunity they
stole UN food supplies in just one case
they still UN food supplies from 160,000
hungry and starving people quote for
political and military weapons as a
weapon they have run sex slave networks
they would abduct their own people they
would sell them into sex slaves to help
prop up their regime or their their
pseudo regime they instituted strict
Sharia law that flogged women for being
seen with men in public who were not
their own relatives
the Taliban have accounted for 80% of
civilian casualties in Afghanistan in
recent years
Taliban murdered aid workers murdered
journalists they harbored helped and
supported and fought alongside Osama bin
Laden before during and after the 9/11
attacks they are the worst people on
earth now how do we deal with them
because all of that you can you can say
everything that's true about these
little devils the Taliban but the
question the President Trump is trying
to solve is the political question we've
been in Afghanistan now for 18 years how
much longer are we gonna stay there how
do we get out what is the resolution of
this conflict there is a lot of
misinformation a lot of bad common sense
going around we'll get into what it
really looks like in Afghanistan what a
future looks like there how we could
ever come to some terms with the Taliban
but first we've got to talk about
stamps.com
I do not go to the post office myself I
love the post office they obviously
fulfill an important task me I'm a
millennial I don't want to leave my
chair stamps.com makes it's so easy they
bring all of the amazing services of the
u.s. post office right to your computer
whether you're a small office sending
invoices or you're an online seller
shipping out products or even if you're
a warehouse sending thousands of
packages a day
stamps.com can handle it all with ease
they're just terrific simply use your
computer to print official US postage
24/7 for any letter any package any
class of mail anywhere you want to send
it we love it here at the daily wire
saves us a lot of time saves us a lot of
money personally saves me a lot of
headaches
once your mail is ready you just hand it
to your mail carrier or you drop it in a
mailbox it's that simple with stamps
calm you get five cents off every first
class stamp you get up to 40% off
Priority Mail stamps calm is a
no-brainer saves you time and money do
it I get on you people all the time
about this because I'm a little bit lazy
in these activities too you just think I
don't want to get started I don't and
it's okay I'll just keep doing it the
way we've been doing it forever 700
thousand small businesses use it you
should too it's just it's just so so
much time so much money so much effort
if you just do it now right now my
listeners get a special offer that
includes a four-week trial plus free
postage and a digital scale without any
long-term commitment how much easier can
I make it for you go to stamps come
right now click on the microphone that's
top of the homepage type in Noel's KRW
l es that is stamps.com and then you
enter no skin o WL es so what do you do
about Afghanistan there is a common
refrain a common canard out there that
Afghanistan is unconquered you hear this
on the left you hear it in the center
you hear it on the right it's folly to
go into Afghanistan it's unconquered
below one's ever conquered Afghanistan
that's just simply not true that is
unhistorical it's what happens when
people don't study history for a long
time of course Afghanistan is
conquerable many people have conquered
Afghanistan over history the Taliban can
conquered Afghanistan just 25 years ago
you certainly can conquer Afghanistan
but - and now it's looking like three
groups have failed to conquer
Afghanistan very conspicuously the
English the Soviets and probably the
Americans the English failed to conquer
Afghanistan in the 19th century the
Soviets failed to conquer Afghanistan in
the 20th century and the Americans it
looks like have failed to conquer
Afghanistan in the 21st century we
didn't fail to conquer
ganha Stan because it's unconquered it's
not like we lost a war we failed to
conquer Afghanistan because we don't
want to conquer it of all those three
the only ones who really wanted to
conquer it were the Soviets and even
then they were just fighting a proxy war
in the Cold War with the Americans we
don't want it we don't want Afghanistan
to be the 51st state
we don't want Puerto Rico to be the 51st
state we might want Greenland to be the
51st state we'll have to see how those
go that's the art of the deal if we want
to invite anyone to Camp David for peace
negotiations we should probably invite
the prime minister of Denmark so we can
talk about how we're taking Greenland
from them that's a point for another day
we don't want Afghanistan we don't we
don't want to bring it in we don't want
to build a country there we don't want
to bring our country there so what do
you do about it because we have been in
Afghanistan for a long time now we
recognize the head of state in
Afghanistan
his name is Ashraf Ghani he's the head
of Afghanistan but is he really the
Taliban is coming back in reconquering
territory and the Taliban sure doesn't
recognize him so what do we do certainly
we should not be in direct official
talks on US soil with the Taliban it
just doesn't make any sense because we
don't recognize the Taliban as the
legitimate government of Afghanistan now
look I'm all for realpolitik we can
negotiate with anybody as long as it
serves our interests and gets our troops
home and makes us safer will negotiate
with anybody that's fine I'm not saying
we need to play by the Marquess of
Queensbury rules here statecraft and
diplomacy or a very ugly thing or they
can be ugly but it's hard to see the
upside here what's the upside of
negotiating with the Taliban on US soil
what's the upside to negotiating with
the Taliban at the presidential retreat
I guess you couldn't do it at the White
House there you probably see the Taliban
walking down the street on 1600
Pennsylvania Avenue they're walking up
you probably get some press about that
but you're gonna get press even if they
go to Camp David direct negotiation with
the Taliban on US soil directly
undermines 20 years of American war
efforts it undercuts our actual national
policy which is to recognize the leader
of Afghanistan as Ghani and
it irritates everybody in the country
left right and center everyone is
irritated that we would have these
despicable disgusting Devils all of whom
should be killed and burn in hell the
Taliban on US soil days before the 18th
anniversary of 9/11 in which they were
complicit Trump realize this and he
called it off huh good I'm glad to hear
it what does this tell us about the
Trump administration the political
significance that's being reported on
now so take it with a grain of salt but
this does ring true is that this is a
fight between the State Department and
John Bolton that's it's a fight between
Mike Pompeo and John Bolton who is the
National Security Advisor the State
Department generally has a kind of
reputation for being more liberal and
preferring diplomacy and you know John
Bolton has a reputation for wanting to
bomb every everyone who's ever looked at
him cross cross and the history of his
life Pompeyo reportedly wanted the talks
Bolton did not want the talks I'm with
Bolton on this if the reporting is
correct you know I'm not against talks
generally there was a big upside to the
talks with Kim jong-un and I supported
those talks with Kim jong-un and I
continued to support the the Trump
outreach to North Korea I pointed that
out at the time but there was no upside
to the Taliban talks so it was good on
the president to call them off you know
he wants to get out of Afghanistan we
all want to get out of Afghanistan but
President Trump needs to be very careful
not to make the mistakes of Barack Obama
which is being so excited about getting
out of Afghanistan that you make
mistakes and you bog us down in
Afghanistan even longer that's what
Obama did it when you negotiate from
weakness when you give up too much
leverage you you you put yourself in a
more dangerous position than you were in
in the first place fortunately president
from woke up to that it seems too
decided with John Bolton which is a very
good idea this is the general theme here
though you know the democracy is the
worst form of government except for all
of the others that have been tried
President Trump who we can criticize
when he does wrong
you know we've criticized him a few
times he made a few missteps you can
you can go out there believe the
mainstream media narrative and you can
say president Trump is the worst
president in recent memory except for
all of the other ones that we've tried
that that holds for the presidential
candidates running against him in the
Democratic Party that holds for his
opponents in the Republican Party who
are trying to primary him it's a joke
but they're still trying to do it and
that holds even for past presidents
Trump has made some mistakes fortunately
in this case he was key corrected that
mistake before it actually occurred but
overall it seems like he's doing a
pretty decent job you don't just need to
take my word for it here you can you can
even listen to James Madison and augment
Asst former Secretary of Defense widely
admired by the country on both sides of
the aisle he is in some ways defending
Trump here and he's criticizing Barack
Obama because American policy in the
Middle East is very very complicated as
a doctor Johnson said all shallows are
clear we'll see there's a bombshell new
book that mattes has dropped the left
was hoping for a bombshell book savaging
the Trump administration what they got
was exactly the opposite we'll get to
that in one second and we'll get to what
it means in 2020 but first I have got to
tell you about movement you know how
much I love movement I wear my movement
watch all the time Atlas revolver super
cool watch I've got more compliments on
it than any watch I've ever round and
I'm going to watch since I was eight
years old movement then makes sunglasses
very sleek sunglasses get compliments on
those too but now they're making
something that has like real tangible
can actually seriously affect your day
beyond the style beyond looking cool
beyond looking compliments before
telling the time and protecting from the
Sun think about how much time you spend
in front of a screen your cell phone
screen your computer screen I'm on a
screen 24 hours a day my wife and I'll
be sitting on the same couch at night
will be scrolling like mindless drones
you know up and down and up and down and
what movement has done is they've got a
product out there that will protect you
from blue light I love movements ever
scroll blue light filtering glasses that
are built to protect your eyes from blue
light that are known to cause eye strain
discomfort and poor sleeping patterns I
got tuned into this
a few years ago coz a pal of mine
actually had started a company around
this issue of blue light it sounds like
something that's not a big deal I have
been using this technology these
movement ever scroll glasses it totally
changes your ability to fall asleep in
mine you get to round up when you're
looking at that regular screen blue
light up until the wee hours of the
morning then you have trouble falling
asleep the average person spends 7 hours
of a day in front of a screen movements
blue light glasses help to change those
habits so you can keep up with a
changing technological world they're
just great I have found this is just
just me telling you but I have found I
get to sleep much easier when I filter
out that blue light you should really
give it a try especially cuz they start
at just 65 bucks whether you're at the
office scrolling through your phone or
unwinding from a long day ever scroll
glasses have you covered I now do not
look at screens without filtering out
that blue light check it out you'll get
better sleep better style get 15% off
today with free shipping and free
returns by going to MVM t.com slash
anoles cana wles shop movement ever
scroll blue light filtering glasses
protect your eyes and nice advantage of
doing it with movement leaders in style
you'll look great while you do it
MVM t.com / knowles join the movement so
don't take my word for it
that it's not just President Trump
bundling the Middle East these problems
started a long time ago president Trump
inherited a lot of problems he's trying
to resolve what is basically America's
longest-running conflict secretary
defense James Madison memoir out and
it's getting play because he's attacking
Obama in it he's not attacking President
Trump and here's mattis explaining why
he won't attack President Trump I prefer
having parted from the administration
over matters of policy of a disagreement
and I laid those out in the letter I
think that what I now occupier would I
call the cheap seats I'm not responsible
so I can sit on the outside and frankly
it it frustrates me sometime to see
people who speak so authoritative Lee
when they don't know the back-channel
things going on and when they have no
responsibility for the outcome
so the French call it a dev water
reserve Christian where you have a duty
to be a quiet this president the
Secretary of State the Secretary of
Defense they have big responsibilities
right now and I don't believe that that
I add anything to it by representing
contrary views or something like this
there will come a time when it's right
for me to talk about strategy and
policies when might that happen I will
know it when I see it but would it be
before the next election I I can't say
that I love mattis the guy is just so in
control of himself
don't forget mattis was built up by
President Trump is this great incredible
guy then Trump started attacking mattis
he started going after him once mattis
left as secretary defence and mattis
just as a class act the guy holds
himself with such dignity there are some
people in politics who hold themselves
with the pretense of dignity they
pretend to be had to have class mattis
really does seem like the real deal he
says I just don't think I should be
attacking the sitting president from the
cheap seats says well when will you I'll
know it when I see it well will it be
before 2020 I'm not at liberty to
discuss that
I'm not I'm not gonna give it to you
Christiane Amanpour who drew Cole's
Christian I'm a poor journalist on CNN
he's just not going to give it to them
and he's exactly right not to so he
won't hit Trump this is the right
decision I think it is so despicable
when former administration staffers
start attacking their boss you know in
Dante in in hell he writes Dante's
Inferno he divides up hell between all
the different sins and all the different
sinners and then as Dante's going down
through hell on his way to purgatory and
then up to heaven he's going down and he
meets and he speaks to all of the
different sinners so you have sins of
the flesh you know early on sins like
lust that sort of thing then as you get
lower you get a worse and worse sins
more evil sins more wicked sins and at
the very bottom you have fraud and
deception people who who are traitors at
the very bottom and in the lowest circle
of hell are those people who betray
their benefactor
they are the ones who are in the
three-headed mouth of Satan being
chomped down for eternity
Judas Brutus and Kassius those who
betray Christ those who betray Caesar
being chomped to death that is in
Dante's mind in the Christian
imagination the Christian understanding
that the worst sort of sin in hell that
is what you see regularly in politics it
tells you a lot about politics that that
is the main thing you go and you work
for a guy and then you immediately leave
and start thrashing him and stab him in
the back
I remember this during the bush to
administration Scott McClellan was press
secretary the minute he left he goes out
and he writes a tell-all memoir about
how terrible Bush was and this has
happened a lot in the Trump
administration people leave and they
stab him in the back
Omarosa did that Anthony scare Moochie I
actually like Anthony scare Moochie but
he did exactly the same thing other
people and left the administration
stabbed the guy in the back and
Madison's not going to do that Madison's
not gonna gonna debase himself to put
himself in the lowest circle of hell
very admirable he will however hit Barak
Obama because what madness is talking
about in that interview is he does have
a responsibility to give his thoughts on
strategy this is a dignified guy he's
spent a lot of time in the US military
he's a very learn it guy they called him
a monk warrior I think he's never got
married he would just read a lot of
books and go fight and kill people so
there is a time when he needs to give us
thought on strategy but he's not gonna
do it to the sitting president he will
hit Barack Obama he just came out and
savaged Barack Obama's handling of Iran
specifically something we didn't know
about an Iranian plot to bomb a cafe in
Washington DC so here's here's mattis's
account of it he said that there was a
plot backed by Iran to bomb a cafe in
Washington DC and after this was foiled
Eric Holder the Attorney General and
robert muller yes that guy you remember
robert muller of the miller
investigation he was FBI director they
came out they held a press conference
and they treated it as a law enforcement
matter okay we caught these criminals
who tried
mccafé they didn't treat it as a matter
of statecraft of foreign policy even
though it was backed by Iran and here is
mattis's account from the book he says
quote had the bomb gone off those in the
restaurant and on the street would have
been ripped apart blood rushing down
sewer drains it would have been the
worst attack on us since 9/11 I sensed
that only Iran's impression of America's
impotence could have led them to risk
such an act within a couple miles of the
White House absent one fundamental
mistake the terrorists had engaged in an
undercover DEA agent in an attempt to
smuggle the bomb the Iranians would have
pulled off this devastating attack had
that bomb exploded it would have changed
history why did the Obama administration
play down this attack because they were
desperate for the Iran deal they were
negotiating from a position of weakness
they totally misjudged America's role in
the world and our role in relation to
our adverse or adversaries abroad mattis
goes on he says quote in my military
judgment America had undertaken a poorly
calculated longshot gamble he's talking
about the Iran deal at the same time the
administration was lecturing our Arab
friends that they had tried to
accommodate Iran as if it were a
moderate neighbor in the region and not
an enemy committed to their destruction
that is a major devastating mistake so
well everybody today is going and
criticizing President Trump for
attempting to hold these Taliban
negotiations by the way I'm one of the
people criticizing him for that keep
this in mind you've got to keep the
context in mind politics is all about
context you're coming off the heels of a
presidential administration that
downplayed what could have been
potentially the deadliest attack in the
United States the most significant
attack in the United States since
September 11th and they did that because
if their own bungled idiotic view of
foreign policy now President or rather
James Madison to defend president from
again and you'll see in just the way
that Democratic strategists
different candidates are talking about
the left and the right right now you see
the context of all of this we are in
extraordinarily trying political times
abroad and with trying political times
at home and in this President Trump with
all its warts I think comes out as the
least bad option which makes him by
definition the best option we'll get to
that in a second we'll get to how
politics is complicated we'll get to
what that means for 2020 first I've got
to say goodbye to Facebook and YouTube
head on over to Daley wire.com what do
you get you get me you get the end of
Clavin show you get the Ben Shapiro show
you get the Matt Walsh row you get to
ask questions in the mailbag that's
coming up on Thursday you get another
Kingdom which is by the way that's
coming out pretty soon we're working on
season three of another Kingdom you get
all of it and you get the leftist cheers
tumblr important every single day is
this 2020 election goes onward make sure
to get that tumblr or you'll drown go to
daily wire.com we'll be right back
you can probably hear it in my voice I'm
a little bit under the weather today so
it's very important for me to heat up my
leftist tears this is everyone has their
own hot toddy recipe you know they throw
a little - whiskey a little bit of honey
maybe some kind of tea or water for me
the secret to a really good hot toddy
and the way to really clear yourself out
is to add that little saline solution
which only comes if you want the very
best in the form of left to steer so you
definitely need to get that tumbler
madis doesn't only go out and say I'm
not going to criticize Trump he doesn't
only go out and say I'm gonna assail the
Obama administration for their idiocy
but he actually defends President Trump
against some attacks that he judges
unfair and that I judge unfair on MSNBC
specifically attacks the president Trump
has undermined NATO since his
inauguration in the last two and a half
years they baby no alliances weekend in
NATO certainly in in Asia and in Europe
you know envy if you take a look at
current events you can always see the
tensions because that's what grabs your
attention is the tensions and those
alliances however right now you see a
NATO that for I think we're into the
fourth straight year or fifth straight
year of the nation's almost all of them
increasing their defence budget so I
could say quantitatively NATO's actually
stronger today now there are political
tensions those tensions have always been
there in NATO where the American
presidents I remember all the way back
to President Clinton when I became aware
of this issue President Clinton
President Bush President Obama all
saying the same thing President Trump is
you've got to pay more the way I carried
the message to NATO when I first went
there as a Secretary of Defense was I've
sat in this room and you've heard this
message before but the American people
are saying they will not care more about
your children's future than you care
you've got to pay your fair share
absolutely right and this is the key
here not just to defend Trump though I
think he has been very unfairly attacked
on his handling of NATO he has achieved
long-standing US goals with regard to
NATO by taking a tough line on it he's
done everything exactly right on
and the attacks on his handling of NATO
in particular are completely unfair but
I actually don't that's sort of
secondary in madison remarks what I'm
interested in is he says that he's heard
these kind of statements before he's
given these kind of statements to NATO
of the fore since certainly since the
Clinton administration we've heard this
and and that's the issue when it comes
to foreign policy presidents come and go
and the foreign policy challenges remain
the same and the national interests of
different countries tends to remain the
same and they tend to supersede the
individual politicians and personalities
who are in there so when it comes to
Afghanistan you can't just blame Trump
you can't just blame Obama you can't
just blame Bush who invaded Afghanistan
you can't even just blame Clinton you
can't just blame Bush one or Reagan
these are problems that that have
spanned decades and decades and
centuries and centuries you know in the
United States who are we gonna blame for
this eighteen year war we've had in
Afghanistan longest u.s. conflict in
history just about Bush invaded sure
Obama said he was gonna hand those Wars
he didn't end those Wars he expanded
that war in Afghanistan Trump said he
was gonna end the war he hasn't managed
to do that yet Clinton doesn't get off
the hook though Bill Clinton is the one
who failed to take action against Osama
bin Laden who then successfully launched
an attack on September 11th which
dragged us back into that war in
Afghanistan because when it comes to war
your opponents have a say - if Clinton
or Bush had responded to the the bombing
of the USS Cole by by bin Laden if
Clinton had responded forcefully to the
first World Trade Center bombing in 1993
the world might look very different
today and our strategy in Afghanistan
might look very different today as well
so have you gonna attack a trump on this
that's fine but make sure it you you
give him his due and you give it the
correct criticism to his predecessors as
well he may be the worst president that
we've had in recent memory but what
about all the other ones he's it also
that this kind of criticism that's
coming in when you look at his opponents
on the left and the right it does seem
there quite a lot worse I mean even
David Axelrod who was the chief
strategist for Barack Obama is coming
out against Joe Biden is coming out
against the Democratic frontrunner
a tweet over the weekend he said quote
it's one thing to have a well-earned
reputation for goofy harmless gaffes
it's another if you see really distort
your own record Joe Biden is in danger
of creating a more damaging meme this
was directly in response to Joe Biden
lying about his his record on the Iraq
war kind of like John Kerry said I was
against the war before I was for the war
Joe Biden is now saying he never really
supported the Iraq war the Bush
administration lied to him about the
Iraq war and what it was about and he
didn't really mean it and he's just
lying he's lying about his support for
the Iraq war this is what I really like
about David Axelrod he is a really good
political analyst because he's not a
hack he was a hack for much of his
career but then when he turned into an
analyst he really became a serious
analyst and this is a big issue for
Biden which I've been calling for weeks
and weeks now I said it's not about the
little lies it's not about the sort of
things that politicians say to to make
people like them to make them seem more
sympathetic it's not about the
glad-handing it's not about the kisses
on the forehead what it's about or the
pathological lies what it's a batter the
serious lies you know Joe Biden lied
about the death of his wife and daughter
tragic death of his wife and daughter
he baselessly smeared the the other
driver involved in that car accident in
1972 of being a drunk the police found
the guy totally innocent that the death
wanted that driver until 1999 when he
himself died then immediately afterward
Biden smeared him as a drunk I mean he's
willing to tell he's really deep lies
and so goofy Uncle Joe who can't
remember the details that's one thing he
can get past that in a campaign but Joe
Biden who's willing to tell all of these
really serious vicious awful needless
lies that's a different thing so you're
gonna run against President Trump
because he has a unique relationship
with the truth let's call him he
exaggerated his crowd sizes at his
inauguration okay who cares if you're
gonna run against him on that on the
question of lying and honesty and
integrity you probably should be honest
yourself and Joe Biden simply is not
David Axelrod calls it out perfectly you
know even the most allegedly nice
moderate Midwestern
Christian Democratic candidate Pete
Budaj
is a radical he's unlikable when it
comes down to it compared to President
Trump here is Buddha judge who only
exists
his entire raison d'etre is to troll
actual Christians by saying I'm more of
a Christian than you hmm actually
Christianity is the opposite of what you
think it is uh I'm a real Christian I'm
not one of those questions
he's now defending post birth abortion
not just abortion not just abortion um
until the point of birth actually
abortion after birth has both biblical
and Christian here he is on the radio
show The Breakfast Club now right now
they hold everybody in line with this
one kind of piece of doctrine about
abortion right which is obviously a
tough issue for a lot of people to think
through morally then again you know
there's a lot of parts of the Bible to
talk about how life begins with breath
and so even that is something that we
can interpret differently and I'm
pro-choice pickup me too
but I think no matter where you think
about the kind of cosmic question of how
life begins most Americans can get on
the board with the idea of all right I
might draw the line here you might draw
the line there but the most important
thing is the person who should be
drawing the line is the woman making the
decision absolutely and I think that if
you're a man who's against abortion you
haven't gotten the wrong woman pregnant
I mean wife I'm just saying we've had
some slip-ups and I've had a few areas
there's the Christian candidate Buddha
judge Pete Buddha judge is the worst
kind of heretic beep boo de jedge is the
worst kind of anti Christian because he
just totally perverts and distorts and
in versts the very Gospel message he
says there's some language in the Bible
about life having a relation to breath
which of course there is I mean in the
very beginning God creates the world on
his own breath right and and he creates
the though on his breath he creates the
world and how does he create the world
by speaking it through the word which is
the Incarnate God
here are some other lines just to
criticize if P Buddha judge and here
just to clarify rather if he Buddha
judges watching God created man in His
image and the divine image he created
him male and female he created them the
act of creating
human beings is to create them in God's
image in Genesis be fruitful and
multiply not be fruitful and then
slaughter the baby before it's born
I have brought forth a man with the help
of the Lord Genesis truly children are a
gift from the Lord the fruit of the womb
is a reward
doesn't sound very pro-abortion to me
the Prophet Amos condemns the ammonites
quote because they ripped open expectant
mothers and Gilead exactly in the way
that people judge is encouraging people
to do in the psalm psalm 139 you knit me
in my mother's womb nor was my frame
unknown to you when I was made in secret
Psalm 22 you have been my guide since I
was first formed from my mother's womb
you are my god until putas judge rips me
apart with forceps in a vacuum God from
my mother's womb had set me apart and
called me from His grace st. Paul
writing to the Galatians I could go on
and on and on I'm actually just quoting
different lines compiled by father Frank
Frank Pavone who's a terrific guy a head
of priests for life you can just google
his his article on this so many biblical
references but people who judge doesn't
care about that because he doesn't care
about the gospel because he's a fake
Christian and an anti-christian the
worst kind of heretic a terrible radical
and an awful jerk which I have been
calling for a long time I did a whole
episode about a pea Buddha judge is such
a jerk
these are the guys who say that they
have some kind of moral credibility to
criticize Trump because Trump was has
been married multiple times and he slept
with a lot of women cheated on his wife
not defending any of those things those
are all terrible things politics
requires context though look at Pete
Buddha judge perverting the very word of
God itself to justify slaughtering
babies how absolutely despicable you
know he's not a member it seems of any
sort of formally constituted church so
he can't be excommunicated but he
certainly should be booted Church those
are the guys to the left of Trump those
are the nice guys to the left of Trump I
didn't even get into the guys who are
considered the actual sort of mean
crueler radical types how about Trump's
challengers to the right you know
President Trump now has this is big news
today he has a new primary challenger in
the Republican Party this one the most
ridiculous one yet mark Sanford former
governor of South Carolina former
congressman from South Carolina's first
District and
former lover boy who abdicated his
office so that he could go cheat on his
wife with his mistress in Argentina here
is Mark Sanford making his announcement
on Fox News Sunday I think we need to
have a conversation on what it means to
be a Republican I think that it's a
Republican Party we have lost our way
and I'd say so on a couple of different
fronts I'd say first and sort of the
epicenter where I'm coming from is that
we have lost our way on debt and
deficits and spending you know one of
the hallmarks of the Republican Party
and the conservative movement has always
been how much do we spend him it was
Milton Friedman's notion of the ultimate
measure of government is how much it
spins I think as a party we've lost our
way the president has called himself the
king of debt has a familiarity and
comfort level with debt that I think is
ultimately leading us in the wrong
direction we can get into those numbers
but the numbers are astounding
I just take for instance as a data point
this last debt deal that adds two
trillion dollars of additional debt to
our country over the next ten years adds
a third of a trillion dollars in new
spending and really there wasn't
conversation on that so I'd say the
epicenter where I'm coming from is we
have got to have a national conversation
and a Republican conversation on where
are we going what an unbelievably
misguided announcement what an
unbelieving in here I mean it's so
absurd that this man is running this man
is maybe the biggest laughingstock of
politicians in the country he's up there
with rod Blagojevich and a few other
disgraced governors but even if he's
gonna do it to roll out this campaign
and basically say I'm running for
president vote for me because Trump
spends money irresponsibly who cares I
mean what he's doing here is he's
running a campaign from 2010 in 2019
2010 you had the rise of the Tea Party
you had the debt and the deficit as
central political issues mitch Daniels a
guy who I tried to get to run for
president talked about the new Red
Menace this one consisting of ink how
the debt was the big ticking time bomb I
agree with that I think it's a very
important issue I was working in
politics to try valiantly or as
valiantly as we could to fix that
problem and everybody failed all those
politicians who tried to fix the debt
failed Paul Ryan made good attempts to
do it and he failed the
no political appetite to fix the debt
and to fix the deficit so what do we
conclude from this to give up know what
I think the smarter people and the wiser
observers of politics concluded is that
trying this fiscal only approach we just
talk about the debt just talk about the
deficits don't talk about anything else
one line that a lot of people were using
at the time was social truce
we're gonna forget about the social
issues for a second we're and put that
on pause and we're gonna fix our debt
and deficit that approach is not
workable that approaches fundamentally
misguided what we learned from that
failure is that we need to fix the
culture in order to fix the fiscal
situation the prot the first problem is
cultural Andrew Breitbart called and
politics is down from culture and what
we know from Russell Kirk and many
others is that politics is down or that
culture rather is down from religion
this guy mark Sanford in a lot of other
old guard establishment types did not
get the memo and they're still running
on the same tired platitudes the other
reason that this is ridiculous notice
I'm I'd like to dismantle mark Sanford's
candidacy simply on the policy arguments
that he's making simply on the way that
he's waging it there's also the
character question which is that this
guy has absolutely no credibility he's
running a campaign based on
responsibility right that's basically
what he's saying president Trump has
been irresponsible in office so elect me
and I will be more responsible elect me
mark Sanford the guy who literally
stopped showing up for work for weeks
and then lied about where he was people
said that he was on the Appalachian
Trail actually though I Mark Sanford
went all the way to freaking Argentina
to cheat on my wife with my mistress in
South America vote for me responsibility
Sanford 2020 are you kidding me
these is cartoonishly irresponsible one
of the least responsible politicians in
recent history who were Trump's other
challengers Joe Walsh Joe Walsh is
running he's a one-term congressman he
was kind of a tea party guy one of the
most bombastic personalities in that era
of politics he's running because Trump
is too mean in his tweets Joe Walsh has
sent far far more offensive tweets than
president from Joe Walsh has been far
far Trumpy or even than Trump
now he's running and saying vote for me
because I'm not as Trump piaced Trump as
of five minutes ago before that time I
was much more Trump II no credibility at
all and then the other guy running is
bill weld who's a liberal Republican
totally liberal northeastern Republican
who is going nowhere he ran as the vice
presidential candidate on the
libertarian ticket in 2016
he's the other guy these are the jokers
I get it I get the argument when you say
President Trump has done bad things okay
yeah he's done a few things I disagree
with call him at for it yeah yeah that's
why we need to elect Mark Sanford
instead what on earth are you talking
about and I don't think this is really
gonna matter because a lot number of
states are canceling primaries right now
and the anti-trump forces the guys
trying to run guys like Mark Sanford and
and Joe Walsh and bill weld are furious
about this bill kristol and personally I
still like but he's really lost it on
this Trump thing he is shocked defended
terrifies comparing this to you know
tin-pot dictatorships in the banana
republics this is all going around on
Twitter because states are canceling
certain primaries for the GOP this has
all happened before this has happened
many times before Arizona didn't hold a
Democratic primary in 2012 why because
Barack Obama was going to do it
1996 Arizona didn't hold up a primary in
the Democratic Party because Bill
Clinton was already the president Kansas
didn't have a Democratic primary in 96
and South Carolina didn't have a
Republican primary in 1984 when Reagan
was running for re-election or in 2004
when Bush was seeking a second term at
South Carolina also skipped in 96 and
2012 on the Democratic side and in 1992
when there actually was a really serious
primary challenge not a Mark Sanford
primary challenge I can actual one
between Pat Buchanan and George HW Bush
several states that year skipped the
Republican primaries Buchanan didn't
whine about it you Bush won it fair and
square
this is totally normal it's happened
many times before all of it requires
context even when you're talking about
bringing the Taliban on vacation with
you to Camp David which is egregious and
I'm glad it didn't happen when you're
talking about wars in Afghanistan when
you're talking about trumps
personal behavior it's just this
attitude that we have in this country
now we can so clearly see everyone
else's faults but it's very difficult to
see our own faults we judge everybody
else on their actions we judge ourselves
on our intentions we're plucking the
little speck of dust out of our
neighbours eye well we have a giant
plank in our own eyes again just like
the fiscal situation just like the
military problems that we've had
overseas in foreign policy this is
ultimately a cultural problem what do we
want as a people what sort of people do
we want to be you can't blame that on
your politicians they are a reflection
of you you've got to fix that in
yourselves can we fix it in ourselves
that's ultimately the question that's
gonna be on the ballot in 2020 that's
our show tune in tomorrow in the
meantime I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Nolt show I'll see you then
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis clever
and our technical producer is Austin
Stephens assistant director Pavel why
douse key edited by Danny D'Amico audio
is mixed by Mike core Amina hair and
makeup is by Joshua alvera and our
production assistant is NIC Sheehan the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright day Lee Weyer 2019
if you prefer facts over feelings if you
aren't offended by the brutal truth if
you can still laugh at the nuttiness
filling our national news cycle well
tune on it into the Ben Shapiro show or
you'll get a whole lot of that and much
more we'll see you there